voilà une avalanche d'armes même si la
contre-offensive ukrainienne se fait
toujours attendre les combats les plus
violents se concentre toujours autour de
barmouth dans l'Est depuis 9 mois
maintenant la mélisse Wagner est en
première ligne elle dit subir de
nombreuses pertes et elle aurait proposé
un deal aux Ukrainiens bonjour Sonia
dready vous êtes à Washington c'est le
Washington Post qui relate cette
histoire disons étonnante
oui en effet c'est une réelle relation
du Washington Post et selon le quotidien
et bien le chef de la milice Wagner
Prigogine à plusieurs fois proposé aux
renseignements ukrainien de lui fournir
des informations sur l'emplacement
d'unité de l'armée russe et cela en
échange d'un retrait des forces
ukrainiennes de backmouth c'est là où se
trouve les hommes de Wagner qui sont en
première ligne et ils combattent dans
une féroce bataille alors le Washington
post-10 appuyer pour ses révélations sur
des documents des services secrets
américains qui ont fuité et sur des
témoignages de responsables
ukrainiens et américains anonymes alors
de son côté le chef de Wagner dément ces
informations il les a qualifiés de
risible le Washington Post a notamment
écrit et bien que le chef de Wagner ce
serait rendu dans un pays d'Afrique
qu'il ne nomme pas pour rencontrer des
membres des renseignements des services
de renseignement Ukrainiens mais
privilégie n'assure qu'il ne s'est pas
rendu en Afrique depuis le début du
conflit entre la entre de la guerre en
Ukraine alors de son côté le
porte-parole du Kremlin dénonce ces
informations il dit que ce sont des
intox dans une récente interview
Washington Post le président
ukrainien zellenski n'a pas confirmé ces
informations mais il est resté assez
évasif sur le sujet il faut dire que ces
révélations et bien ont été publiés
alors que la situation est de plus en
plus tendue entre le chef de Wagner et
l'état major russe cela fait des mois
que Prigogine critique l'état major
russe qui selon lui ne fournit pas assez
de munitions à ces hommes qui sont en
première ligne dans la bataille de
barmut et ses critiques sont devenues de
plus en plus virulentes ces derniers
temps puisque il a même publié des
vidéos dans laquelle dans lesquelles
directement il insulte même le chef de
l'état-major russe et le ministre de la
Défense merci pour ces éléments